[Musique]
c'est l'heure du journal de l'Afrique
soyez les bienvenus sur France 24 à la
une ce soir Laurent gbagbo-grandida la
présidentielle de 2024 l'ancien
président ivoirien en a fait à l'annonce
le lundi alors que son parti le ppaci
souffle sa première bougie nous serons à
Abidjan dans ce journal
l'Ouganda face à une épidémie d'Ebola
pour l'instant moins 24 personnes sont
mortes de la maladie il s'agit de la
souche titsoudanaise du virus pour
laquelle aucun vaccin ni traitement
n'est efficace le Rwanda voisin a déjà
pris des mesures reportage à la
frontière entre les deux pays dans ce
journal la date du 17 octobre 1961 une
manifestation d'Algériens étaient
violemment réprimé à Paris l'an dernier
Emmanuel Macron avait qualifié les faits
de crime inexcusable beaucoup ont estimé
que le chef de l'État n'était pas allé
assez loin faut-il s'attendre à d'autres
étapes dans ce dossier mémorial avec
l'Algérie nous avons abordé ce thème
avec l'historien Fabrice riskouti il
était notre invité tout à l'heure
Laurent Gbagbo et candidat la
présidentielle en Côte d'Ivoire il a
annoncé ce lundi alors que son parti le
ppaci soufflait sa première bougie il en
a profité également pour revenir sur les
problèmes qui touchent les ivoiriens en
cette période de crise notre
correspondante à Abidjan c'est à dire
bonjour était sur place cela faisait
plusieurs mois que l'ancien président
Laurent Gbagbo n'avait pas fait de
déclarations officielle en public pour
le premier anniversaire de son parti le
parti des peuples africains en Côte
d'Ivoire il a donné rendez-vous après de
1000 membres exécutifs du parti sans
surprise on a appris que Laurent Gbagbo
sera candidat à l'élection
présidentielle de 2025 c'est donc le
retour en politique de lancer en
président après 10 ans d'absence
rappelant que Laurent Gbagbo avait été
condamné par la Cour pénale
internationale à 10 ans de prison avant
d'être acquitté et il n'avait pas pu se
présenter à l'élection présidentielle de
2020 cet anniversaire a aussi été
l'occasion pour l'ancien président de
partager dans un discours d'une heure
sur la politique nationale il a esquissé
un plan de campagne axé sur la lutte
contre la vie chère le respect de la
démocratie et de la liberté d'expression
on l'écoute
il faut qu'on
itule vos
amis en exposition
Laurent Gbagbo connu pour ses prises de
position c'est l'entend attardé sur la
politique Internet notamment les coups
d'État en Guinée et au Burkina Faso et
il a appelé à la libération des 46
soldats d'ivoriens détenus au Mali
depuis trois mois maintenant
sur les starting blocks l'opposant
sénégalais a décidé de faire une tournée
à travers le pays pour aller à la
rencontre de ces militants dans le cadre
de son projet focus 2024 dès le début de
la tournée dimanche c'est partisans ont
été dispersés par la gendarmerie dans
une vidéo l'opposant à dénoncer
l'acharnement du pouvoir la
correspondance à Dakar des limendao dans
une vidéo qui a fait le tour des réseaux
sociaux l'on voit au sein de Sonko
s'expliquer énergiquement avec un
colonel de la gendarmerie selon
plusieurs témoins les gendarmes ont
lancé des grenades lacrymogènes sur la
foule qui acclamait Ousmane Sonko à la
sortie d'une visite de proximité à
Johann à 80 km au sud de Dakar plus tard
dans la soirée dans un live sur facebook
accusé le pouvoir et le président Macky
Sall d'être à l'origine de ces
perturbations tout en précisant que rien
ne l'empêchera de poursuivre sa tournée
politique une tournée qui s'inscrit dans
le cadre tour ou visite de courtoisie à
wolof selon un responsable du parti par
Steph les patriotes le parti de ce
morceau que nous avons joué au téléphone
cette tournée a été financée par le
public à travers un financement
participatif lancé en début 2021 et qui
a permis la mobilisation de plus de 240
millions de francs Cfa l'objectif est de
faire le tour du Sénégal et expliquer au
chèvre religieux coutinier de façon
générale aux populations le projet
politique
Ousmane Sonko et de se donner toutes les
chances de remporter la présidentielle
de 2024
bleu de la mission de l'ONU la minusma
ont été tués et trois autres grièvement
blessés ce lundi par l'explosion d'un
engin explosif improvisé dans le nord du
pays
la situation est très préoccupante en
Ouganda depuis quelques semaines une
épidémie du virus Ébola sévi il s'agit
de la souche ditsudanès de la maladie
une souche contre laquelle aucun vaccin
ni traitement n'était efficace les
picentre se trouve sur un axe très
emprunté au centre du pays le Rwanda
voisin a déjà pris des mesures de
contrôle reportage à la frontière entre
les deux pays signés
en mars dernier des familles ont alors
pu se réunir et le commerce a repris
mais Ébola vient de nouveau ralentir les
échanges
[Musique]
nous avons des frères détentes et des
sœurs en Ouganda
mais nous leur avons expliqué que nous
ne pouvons pas venir avant que bola ne
s'arrête
le Rwanda met en place des exercices
dans ses hôpitaux à Kigali la capitale
les médecins simulent la prise en charge
dans cas suspect face à la rapide
propagation du virus en Ouganda la
totalité des hôpitaux rwandes des
doivent être prêt avant fin octobre le
pays n'a encore jamais été confronté à
une épidémie d'Ebola heureusement nous
n'avons pas eu de cas importés au Rwanda
et c'est grâce à la phase de préparation
nous la prenons très au sérieux et nous
y investissons dans la plupart de notre
temps pour être certain que les
contrôles et la préparation du personnel
sont appropriées
le Rwanda avait déjà mis en place ces
exercices en 2018 lors d'une grande
épidémie dans la région frontalière
selon l'Observatoire volcanique de Goma
les scientifiques sont sur le terrain
pour scruter l'activité du volcan pour
l'instant il se veulent rassurant les
précisions à Kinshasa d'Aurélie bazarra
kibangula avec les images de Justin
camembert
a été lancé par les habitants de mounigi
une ville voisine de Goma ils ont senti
des vibrations dans le sol et entendu
des grondements ils ont aussi observé
une intensification de l'allure rouge
qui s'échappe du cratère du niragongo le
volcan situé au pied de la ville de Goma
ses ressentis des habitants ont été
confirmés par l'Observatoire volcanique
de la ville de Goma depuis mercredi des
scientifiques sont déployés sur le
terrain pour scruter l'activité du
volcan après observation des fissures
ils affirment qu'il s'agissait d'un
mouvement de magma et de séismes des
mouvements qui selon eux ne représentent
pas pour le moment de réel menace
d'éruption mais qui doivent rester sous
surveillance nous avons des capteurs de
température dans les fissures les
températures n'ont pas changé non pas
varier sont restés le même et même le
manager des gaz donc parce que nous
enregistrons la densité des gaz dans
l'efficier c'est gaz aussi n'ont pas
changé notre tablement mais seulement
nous comme
observatoire parce que nous devons nous
nous
essayez de comprendre tout ce qui a
comme moi sur les volcan et donc nous
devrions rester vigilant et continuer à
surveiller l'Observatoire volcanique
tente donc de rassurer au moment où ces
vibrations et ses grondements ont
inquiété les habitants de la ville de
Goma tous se rappellent de l'éruption du
niragongo en mai 2021 les coulées de
lave avait provoqué la mort d'au moins
32 personnes et des milliers d'habitants
avaient fui vers les localités voisines
le 17 octobre 1961 une manifestation
d'Algériens à Paris à l'appel du FLN a
été réprimé dans le sang tir à balles
réel rafle torture et manifestants jetés
dans la Seine une page sombre de
l'histoire qui aujourd'hui fait partie
du dossier mémorial entre l'Algérie et
la France Fabrice riscotti historien
auteur de ici en noyade des Algériens et
co-fondateur du site 1000 autres points
org un site dédié aux disparus de la
guerre d'Algérie était notre invité tout
à l'heure pour lui la qualification de
crime d'État pour cet événement est
nécessaire écoutez
oui en effet ce qu'a fait le président
Macron lors du 60e anniversaire
c'est encore une fois une reconnaissance
qui euphémise ce qui s'est produit en
octobre 61 c'est à dire qu'il ne dit pas
tout ce qui a été qui devrait être dit
et qui fait consensus aujourd'hui chez
les historiens il a
attribué la responsabilité des
événements au seul Maurice Papon comme
si Maurice Papon
n'obéissait pas à des ordres et comme si
en réalité toutes les institutions de la
Cinquième République n'avaient pas été
impliquées à des degrés divers dans
cette dans cette tragédie l'institution
policière qui n'est pas mentionnée dans
le communiqué de l'Elysée qui a perpétré
à participer à la perpétration du crime
mais aussi l'institution judiciaire par
exemple qui a
garanti l'impunité complète
aux policiers et aux responsables de
l'époque bref
tout n'est pas dit tout ne semble pas
encore pouvoir être dit dans le contexte
politique actuel dont le président de la
République est évidemment fortement
tributaire et je suis de ceux qui
pensent que il y a eu c'est
l'institution policière ainsi que les
syndicats de police qui bloquent
toujours sur cet événement qui chaque
fois qu'il est rappelé depuis maintenant
plusieurs décennies provoque des des
indignations sur le fait qu'on aurait
apporterait atteinte à l'honneur de la
police donc ce qui est ce qui a été
difficilement accepté à propos du rôle
de la police pendant
Vichy ne l'est toujours pas sur cette
dans cet épisode sur l'histoire sur
l'histoire coloniale alors lors de son
voyage à Alger fin août le président de
la République a annoncé la création
d'une commission d'historien sur la
colonisation est-ce ultime pour faire
avancer la question mémorielle à votre
avis
écoutez pour l'instant il s'agit d'une
annonce dont on ne sait toujours pas
grand chose de près de de précis exact
cette commission le président de la
République lui attribué un champ de
compétence qui laisse-pantoise les
historiens c'est à dire que s'agirait de
travailler sur toute l'histoire
coloniale de l'Algérie compris donc la
guerre d'indépendance ce qui paraît
totalement absurde et parfaitement
inutile puisque depuis des décennies
maintenant il y a des travaux très
nombreux pas seulement français ou
algériens et aussi anglo-saxons par
exemple dans d'autres pays qui font
consensus sur l'essentiel et il n'y a
nul besoin de commission d'historien à
mon avis pour dire ce qu'a été ce que ce
que n'arrive toujours pas à dire la
France c'est ce qu'a été ce qu'on était
les 132 ans de colonisation de l'Algérie
pour ne parlait que de l'Algérie alors
ensuite est-ce que cette commission aura
accès à des archives qui sont pour
l'instant inaccessibles tant du côté
algérien que du les Français je n'en
sais absolument rien mais sur le
principe même les historiens
se demandent bien pourquoi on donnerait
le privilège d'accéder à certaines
archives à certaines personnes désignées
par les États ce qui ressemblerait une
forme de tutelle de les états sur
l'histoire et qui paraît extrêmement
problématique
voilà c'est la fin de journal de
l'Afrique restez avec nous l'info
continue sur France 24
[Musique]
urgence climatique écrit d'alerte en
Somalie le pays pourtant habitué aux
sécheresses ce meurtri
aux consumés une insécurité alimentaire
grandissante la famine menace
[Musique]
reporter en terre somalienne avoir sur
France 24 et France 24